let's turn the phone lines right now in
the Honda inside a report right now a
good friend of the program welcome back
John Barry how you been John rich I'm
good
before we get started I have to say yes
few weeks I've watched the show on
Sunday and what has happened to your
athleticism or did you ever have any wow
did you can't guard mooch balls off your
fingertips I mean you have no elevation
yes no hands
I mean pathetic well John well no
actually no actually it was in one
single show last week where Thomas Davis
was making his point from the middle of
the set and threw a football to Mariucci
and the other end the set I decided to
try and pick off the football twice in
the same show both times I could not get
up high enough and ended up tip drilling
it to mooch would you like to know the
reason why John yeah tell me my jacket
was in such a way that my my arms
couldn't get up high enough each time it
was the jacket I'm blaming it on line
Taylor John okay I thought it might have
been the phone book that was on the
ground I just think you know plus the
shoes the shoes that I had on you know
there were loafers I mean if there were
lace-ups I think I might have had the
better the better opportunity well look
I'm all right I didn't know it was the
same show I'm giving you credit that I
watched your show two weeks in a row
appreciate does know that bless you John
Barry and I'm sorry about your Falcons I
apologize about that
I live in Atlanta but I mean between
them and the Georgia Bulldogs it's been
it's been tough here in Atlanta in the
state of Georgia it's uh but for me I'm
okay on opener guy okay there we go
very good and you got the bright future
of Jimmy G there's no question about
that let's pay him turn to him they will
don't worry
so uh what why do you think there's been
so much anger amongst players this year
certainly in the recent days John well I
heard your point about referees and
maybe there is some frustration there
and then maybe guys are taking out each
other that could be a valid point I
really don't know what I do know I don't
like to see fighting but I I'm not
opposed to this that this shows me that
guys are caring I like this better than
guys high-fiving and laughing and joking
around with none another that we've seen
because of all the money that we have in
this game and all the friendships that
these guys have I this shows me guys
care so I like the intensity I like the
guys are getting after it I don't like
to see guys throwing punches I don't
like to see guys getting fine and
getting thrown out of games but I like
the passion I mean at least people are
going after it
so let's put the refereeing thing aside
and take this one at a time if you're
Adam Silver what do you do with the
Rockets and Clippers with what happened
the other night yeah you know this
happened before guys have tried to meet
in the back of the arena when you get
underneath most locker rooms are
accessible to one another down a hallway
so it's happened before people have met
in the hallway you know I don't think
it's going to be too much you know
did you see the funny I saw a funny
tweet by the way of Chris Paul that they
said finally Chris Paul led his team
somewhere that was kind of cold yes yes
I don't think it's going to be adding
severe they might get a game you know
all those guys that went over there know
now they're saying Clint capela knocked
on the front door to try to get the
attention over there like come on I mean
these guys couldn't put together a plan
this good in a span of a minute after
the game but nonetheless I don't think
that happened I mean I've seen it before
guys have screamed and yelled down the
hallway trying to get to one another and
look the guys don't want to get into
doing that and we're all sake fighters
in the NBA yeah that's what I was gonna
say it's it's just more fake fighters
NBA or baseball players right yeah well
we have a shot to do it in and their
fines are considerably less so if you
really want to get after somebody and
major leagues you got a great shot to do
it but in the NBA it's gonna cost you a
lot of money so guys know that
I don't think they want to get into that
okay so what about the officiating John
Barry I mean we saw the other night
where Russell Westbrook got hammered
going to the basket it was instead
called the travel he gets teed up so
fast it's he's gone
Carmelo says he's done with the refs
draymond wants all 70 of them replaced
what has happened this year between the
officials and the players the best you
can tell John yeah well you know there's
a lot of new guys and we've lost a lot
of veteran officials over the past four
or five years and I think Carmelo is
white I mean if you go back 10 - 10 15
20 years ago or even longer than that
there was a longer rope that you could
you could get upset a referee would
allow you to kind of vent a little bit
and then he tell you to calm down that's
enough and then you comply and I think
it is there is a quick trigger right now
a lot of these guys are we won't see
Russell Westbrook thrown out he gets hit
in the face obviously a missed call I
mean you got to walk away don't turn
your back like like the NCAA official
and try to show up any players but you
got to give them a little bit of a rope
you tell them hey enough and just let
these guys play but it's a it's a very
difficult job I mean you see we look at
replay and guys are still getting it
wrong so how can you do it at full time
speed it's very difficult these guys are
trying to do the best they can do but
again I think there needs to be some
dialogue they need to get together Adam
Silver is a guy that will take care of
this I'm sure something around the
all-star break something will be done
and look we're all in this together and
hopefully they figure something well
what is that what is it I mean the the
officials representatives along with the
Players Association maybe Chris Paul
who's who's a leader in that regard they
all get together and what a hash it out
and then spread the word essentially you
know yeah you know I don't know what's
what's there is to do I mean there's got
to be some dialogue looking any
communication between both parties has
got to be good and you got to come come
to some common ground but again I think
it's a very difficult job these
guys are playing for a lot and there's a
lot of intensity out there and it's a
you know it is what it is I can't
explain exactly what's going through the
referees minds but I do know it's a very
very difficult job and hopefully we can
get this thing fixed couple more minutes
left with John Barry here in the Honda
inside a report ESPN NBA analyst and
espn.com Dave McMenamin with an
interesting piece out of Cleveland just
a couple of days ago John saying that
some members of the organization some
members of the team are wondering if
this is the first time that whatever
January doldrums are occurring that
there will not be a switch flipped that
this is this may be the the Cavs team
that we see what do you think yeah I'm
not in that camp I did the warrior
Cleveland game on radio Monday night and
I don't see it that way I still think
with LeBron James on that team that's
still the team to beat in the Eastern
Conference I know it looks ugly now
they're in a 3 and 9 stretch but they're
trying to bring back Isiah Thomas who is
a phenomenal player the year he had last
year if he can regain that form I think
this team will put it together I saw no
panic from tyronn lue the head coach as
we spoke before the ball game I don't
see it that way and I'd be surprised if
if players were saying that that they
don't think that this is going to happen
I think there's some guys that are
frustrated with their roles
Tristan Thompson being one Dwyane Wade
is not real comfortable I think in his
role but at the end of the day you have
LeBron James the best player in
basketball and you have plenty of talent
on the team I think they put it together
I don't think they're a DEFCON 5 just
yet so and I know that Anthony Davis had
a hell of a night in Boston and just
beat the Celtics in overtime last night
but you don't think the Celtics are the
team to beat in the East right now with
the way that they played no I don't
I mean LeBrons was in the final seven or
eight straight years and they like I
said they have the talent around them
they're just not playing well right now
they have a malaise seem like seemingly
every year and there anyone now trust me
in a month and a half after the all-star
break
we cruising right along and they'll be
they'll be looking like the team that
would be in the final
do you think Luke Waltons right coach
for the Lakers John I absolutely do and
I'm waiting for Rob palinka to come out
and let everybody know that I'm
surprised that you're gonna let Lavar
ball go off and say this and you don't
have your coaches back well I mean
Jeanne boss did tweet out that she was
flying out to have dinner and Earvin
Magic Johnson tweeted something from
Hawaii and that was by the way a day
after when horse came on this show and
basically said the reason why they're
not saying anything is they really don't
have his back so what what camp do you
put yourself in John well you know I
don't know obviously they can answer
that if Luke's not there guy I'd be
surprised but that's if that's the case
I know they're not the ones that hired
them but even if they don't have his
back you should come out and act like
you support him for right now for the
betterment of your team if you want to
make a move and do something in the
offseason that's entirely up to you but
for right now it makes it a very
difficult work atmosphere for the rest
of these guys a lot of them talking
getting talked about in trades and if
you know that the coach possibly doesn't
have backing of the front office it's
it's it's not an enviable enviable place
to be and you saw this team they really
really struggled playing a little better
of late but I think they should come out
and really have Luke's back and I
believe in Luke Walton I think he's a
terrific young coach John appreciate the
time hopefully this week you know I've
got a six-hour game day morning I might
have two or three opportunities to pick
one off and I'm gonna get up there this
time John I'm gonna work on the hammies
and this week and I'm gonna get up there
I certainly hope I'll be tuning in and
looking forward to the Patriots winning
another Super Bowl okay is that your
pick how can you not I don't know man I
mean what you saw from Minnesota I mean
don't you think that they've got the
defense and somewhat of a football gods
situation that they could be playing a
home game for the Superdome like that
second half defense okay there you go
that's they shouldn't even be playing
let's be honest that happened though
that game 60 minutes long John yeah
I did it alright well chat soon always
take care [ __ ] that's John there the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience